it's really fantastic to be here I'm
super excited I'm from the UK and I grew
up in a really dull boring place a small
town you never have heard of I had a
very Dias childhood I remember one time
when I was a kid no nothing nothing
really terribly boring I'm gonna tell
you about my own children if you'll bear
with me now I know no one wants to hear
about anyone else's kids I didn't care
when my friends started telling me they
were having children I was not good bye
they said what do you mean we can still
hang out sure but we can't you can't
hang out with your friends once they
have children because once your friends
have children your friends may as well
be dead they they never get back to you
they never get back to your messages
they stop returning your phone calls
it's like they died and it all happens
like a line of dominoes Pete and hazel
dead Jenny and Duncan dead oh she died
on her own that was brave and you and
your partner you have a child you passed
through the Vale together oh my god
where dad you wake in some misty foggy
hall with great clouds of diaper creams
scudding by who these figures emerging
from the mist how it's us it everyone
you ever knew who disappeared when they
had children we've been waiting for you
welcome to boring heaven well that
sounds good what is there to do in
boring heaven
we'll come round for a drink during the
day things are looking up what can you
offer me would you like a chamomile tea
have you got anything stronger
oh yes yes we can leave the bag in come
on all I do now my entire life is I get
up at 6:00 a.m. and I stir oatmeal
that's my whole life get up
stir the oatmeal keep the family alive
so much boring food there is oatmeal so
we put honey in it no no keep it boring
stur away the memories I mean I love my
family but they've stolen from me even
the luxury of suicide stir away the
memories I had a threesome once stir it
away stay away well I will say we
communicate with our children very well
they're very communicative kids one and
four years old and we taught them baby
sign language when they were little this
is a real thing I can't recommend it
enough you teach your kids a couple of
simple signs they can communicate with
you way before they can actually speak
so my daughter she's anyone we can say
to a milk she'll understand this milk
turn off a milk biscuit breach breach
snipers three on the roof go a stroke it
could save your life I find the hardest
thing is when me and my wife will go out
on a pathetic date we'll get a
babysitter not for us we're not that
contemporary but to look after the
children we'll get a babysitter as we go
out to like a party but like a 60th
birthday party so basically a pre wake
or even
oh I feel like maybe the rooms have been
older than I'd realize you you're
personally hurt by that I'm so sorry
well we'll go you know we'll just go to
a bar or go to a restaurant within 500
yards of our house in case we need to
get back for the babysitter you know in
case there's a wolf or something and
then we get back home my wife goes
upstairs to take off her makeup because
she's made an effort because she's a
champion and I will be left alone in a
room with a 17 or 18 year old woman who
I've never met before
and with whom I have to make awkward
small talk when I pay her off can regret
that phrasing that's terrible Freddie
but nonetheless it's me and a teenage
woman in a room and I'm so it's so
important to me to make sure that she
doesn't think I'm trying to flirt with
her or god forbid relate to her that in
that moment I spontaneously transform
into a Victorian gentleman and start
doffing an imaginary top hat a pleasure
to meet you imagine Oh God not a
pleasure no no a neutral neutral to meet
you you are in the employment of my
married wife you see to whom I married
by marriage in the traditional fashion I
assure you you're quite safe god that
sounded weird
I trust the children live excellent
excellent
well here am i clattering on you must
think me quite the church bells now here
here are your earnings which I shall
place in a neutral position lest by no
chance might our skin I've said I shall
return now to share my embarrassment
with those below stairs hear her to
Downton Abbey
although obviously that doesn't make any
sense because I'm Victorian and Downton
Abbey is posted Audion but you knew that
I've seen too much thanks so much guys
[Applause]